oh
bonjour et bienvenue pour cette 63e
édition de diagonale tv alors ce soir je
suis particulièrement content d'être là
avec vous parce que cette émission
montre le grand retour de stéphane
laborde
bonsoir stéphane courbon soir nicolas
stéphane laborde qui nous a manqué donc
pendant les trois dernières émissions
qui a également manqué le tournoi de
bordeaux donc on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur ça avec toi stéphane
également ce soir avec nous régissent
jolène donc régis qui est donc le
compositeur notamment donc de l'hymne à
palamède in que vous connaissez pour la
plupart d'entre vous et qui je crois à
savoir va bientôt donner un concert
prochainement donc on aura l'occasion de
revenir sur cet événement en fin
d'émission
bonsoir régis conçoit redécoller qu'il
soit stephen alors stéphane dit nous qui
nous a manqué
tu sais qui nous a manqués alors
explique nous un petit peu explique nous
un petit peu pourquoi tu n'étais pas
alors d'abord je voudrais dire tu disais
que j'étais pas à bordeaux en fait
j'étais un petit peu parce que d'abord
j'ai vu j'ai pu voir grâce à canal où
elle je te revoir le différé de tout le
grand prix de bordeaux
donc j'ai pu me délecter de ce grand de
ce grand spectacle de grâce a donc à la
technique diagonale à la magie du web à
la magie du web exactement bon je
n'étais pas tout à fait absent en fait
il se trouve que diagonale actuellement
est donc en grande émission en grand
changement puisque bombe et déjà nous
développons maintenant une émission en
anglais où tout le monde a pu le voir le
lundi malcom pen devient maintenant de
façon régulière alors pas ces derniers
temps puisque c'est les jours fériés
maintenant le lundi mais de façon
régulière vient de faire son émission en
anglais on prépare une émission
espagnole avec des partenaires espagnols
on prépare peut-être aussi une émission
en allemand et la leçon aussi maintenant
la leçon qui présentait par brett par
bertrand guyard maintenant arriver là
dessus le grand prix de bordeaux et la
semaine prochaine le grand prix du sénat
donc ça fait beaucoup de choses beaucoup
de choses des pour préparer ça il faut
prendre du recul il faut prendre du
recul et donc quitté un peu le devant de
la scène de diagonale pour préparer tout
ça parce qu'il faut faire du sponsoring
il faut faire de la préparation il faut
préparer l'avenir il faut consolider
l'acquis donc voilà toutes les raisons
pour lesquelles j'ai dû m'absenter donc
tout ça pour prendre du recul par
rapport à tout ce travail qu'elle fait
tout pour oublier que j'ai présentées
diagonale pendant plus d'un an et demi
quasiment donc ça depuis décembre 98
j'en ai manqué aucune émission donc à
part les trois dernières donc ça fait
quand même
ça mérite un peu de recul par rapport à
la suite donc tu as pris un petit peu de
souffle tu reviens avec donc des idées
percutante
c'est vrai que quand on regarde le web
actuellement diagonale est présent
partout on est diffusée sur tweets sur
énormément de la fédération sur sport24
porte note
yahoo et avec les événements à venir
comme sarajevo comme le tournoi du sénat
et puis je crois qu'il ya également un
événement de taille très importante en
septembre tu peux nous en dire un peu
plus latioui en octobre novembre il y
aura encore un grand prix donc le
troisième le grand prix de montpellier
donc on peut l'annoncer ce soir grand
prix de montpellier qui aura lieu grâce
notamment à la société ben'z à qui nous
a accompagnés depuis le début du grand
prix de bordeaux société de design et
qui travaille à montpellier pour qu'on
aille puissent investir à montpellier la
place de montpellier pour faire enfin un
grand prix dans le sud de cette fois
sud-est on a fait le sud ouest on a fait
maintenant le sud-est ont fait le grand
prix du sénat on risque faire aussi
c'est très probable un deuxième grand
prix à paris parce que dans prix du
sénat c'est bien mais c'est une belle
vitrine mais il faut accueillir plus de
monde parce que l'exemple du sénat
malheureusement c'est que 200 places
donc c'est que les invitations c'est
dommage parce que tout le monde pourra
pas y assister
les échecs spectacle les échecs
spectacle et voilà donc on veut faire
aussi un spectacle dans un théâtre à
paris donc il y aura aussi un grand prix
à paris après celui de montpellier est
aussi très probablement grand prix à
cannes puisque les organisateurs de
cannes nous ont quémandé pour donc
organiser un grand prix sur le même
modèle que celui de bordeaux qui a eu
deux maintenant depuis quatre ans et
donc il s'avère une vue une réussite qui
cette année donc été vraiment une très
belle réussite à la fois médiatique est
spectaculaire avec la victoire superbe
de michael adams et bien beaucoup de
bonnes choses en perspective dix mois
puis je crois aussi savoir qu'il ya un
site internet propre à diagonale tilly
qui est en construction
oui voilà alors un site
et pointe et ronald tivi points comme ça
y est ce site va voir le jour il a déjà
lieu donc en prototype vous pouvez taper
www point des banales tv.com et vous
allez découvrir un tout nouveau site qui
est dédié exclusivement à des gones
allez donc sur lequel il y aura des
informations des news là les annonces
des émissions les possibilités de
recourir à des moteurs de recherche
particulière pour l'instant ce n'est
qu'à l'état de prototype
il n'est pas encore fini mais vous
pouvez voir à peu près de quoi ça va
avoir l'air en tapant donc les fameuses
lettres diagonale tv.com très bien et
bien je suis assez content de toutes ces
nouvelles
c'est vrai que le tournoi de bordeaux
avait parti que m'avait particulièrement
marqué on remet ça pour le thé noir du
sénat c'est quand même assez génial et
puis ont remis ça une troisième fois
dans l'année avec montpellier
que demander de plus s'est vraiment
c'est vraiment d'en faire alors si tu
veux bien stéphane on va démarrer sur
sur l'actualité sur l'événement très
important de cette semaine doit tout à
fait alors maintenant je vais prendre la
main effectivement pour présenter
l'émission l'euro aujourd'hui dans cette
émission trois grandes parties d'abord
l'événement de la semaine ensuite on
vend analysé suite à cet événement qui
le jaffa classique en indonésie la
partie de la semaine entre yann timan et
judit polgar est en fait nous
reviendrons sur l'actualité de la
semaine dans lequel nous reviendrons sur
le match quatre chefs piquette le ton à
du sénat ainsi que d'autres informations
importantes de cette semaine démarrons
tout de suite par l'événement de la
semaine le jaffa classique
alors voilà donc l'événement de la
semaine le jaffa classique en indonésie
alors nicolas ce tournoi très important
pour le classement international avec
des joueurs de renom c'est clair c'est
un des c'est le plus grand tournoi qu'il
y ait eu lieu en indonésie de tous les
temps et donc ce tournoi qui a lieu du
22 avril jusqu'au 2 mai donc elle qui a
cours actuellement
effectivement donc il ya des supers
joueurs il ya karpov
il ya la numéro un mondiale féminine qui
est judit polgar il ya bien entendu le
champion du monde
alexander qualif man il ya également
d'autres joueurs comme le landais bien
connu yann timan on peut citer également
donc elle veste serra one et d'autres
joueurs encore donc un événement
effectivement très important très
important je te coupe nicolas et qui
prouve que les échecs sont en train
d'acquérir une véritable dimension
mondiale je crois que ça fait très
longtemps depuis l'époque de fisher je
crois même que les tournois d'échecs
comme ça s'exporte dans le monde entier
c'est vrai que en ce moment que si on
regarde bien petit peu ce qui se passe
sur sur le web niveau des échecs et des
tournois quasiment toutes les semaines
des tournois qui sont retransmis en
direct les parties sont en direct un peu
partout aujourd'hui en plus c'est bon il
ya la vidéo avec diagonale titi c'est
vrai qu'on a vraiment l'impression que
depuis un an six mois un an les choses
explosent complètement leur espèce
complètement on parle indonésien je vais
juste faire une anecdote il va aussi y
avoir un grand tournoi en juin à mexico
avec je crois shirov épaules gars qui
vont se retrouver là bas il y aura
quatre joueurs je sais pas quels sont
les deux autres crois qu'il ya qualif
man aussi et je sais plus quel est le
quatrième mais donc mexico l'indonésie
ça il s'en sort de l'europe ça y est
sarajevo également très prochainement
avec kasparov le numéro un
diana krall etienne bacrot pour lequel
on attend énormément
alors effectivement une actualité sans
interruption alors si vous voulez bien
donc on va aller regarder un petit peu
plus en détail le donc l'événement jaffa
donc on vous a présenté les joueurs
le classement caen qu'elle est il
aujourd'hui et bien après combien de
ronde
après donc après quatre rondes un cinq
sur cinq par cinq rondes quotidien après
cinq rondes c'est judit polgar qui mène
qui mène au score alors je crois régis
peut-être tu peux tu peux intervenir
parce que judit polgar tant que tu as
connu sa soeur sofia
puisque tu étais présent au premier
grand prix de bordeaux ou de sofia
pauvre gars étaient étaient là étaient
arrivés en finale
vous n'avez qu'à 26 villages de quoi
s'étonner si bien le cubain jeudi pour
voir en tête d'un tournoi devant karpov
quel effet ça te fais toi qui est un peu
amateur d'échecs
bah disons que c'est c'est chouette
parce que
dit à l'époque que je les rencontre et
déjà elle était elle était vraiment en
pleine ascension et donc de voir cette
année ce qui se passe et c'est vraiment
fabuleux et donc une femme en tête
devant tous les hommes comme ça ça fait
quel effet l'effet que ça ça me fait
c'est un petit peu l'effet que tout le
monde ressent cercle finalement le
cerveau peut être n'a pas de sexe
effectivement donc c'est clair il faut
également poseront marque
il faut préciser que je dit que le gars
est donc dans les 100 premiers mondiaux
à lahitte et je crois dans les dix
premiers mondiaux était 10e une fois à
l'été 10e donc on attend le grand retour
de gîtes et j'ai l'impression que ce
retour est en train là de prendre forme
donc on risque de voir on a toutes les
chances de voir donc judith très
prochainement on prend de prendre
prendre encore de l'ascendant et et tant
mieux pour obtenir tant mieux pour les
échecs tant mieux pour le spectacle
lorsqu on peut noter on parle d'une
retour judith moi je crois qu'on peut
aussi parler de retour de karpov parce
que ça faisait un moment que karpov
faisait des résultats c'est vrai en
dents de scie et faisait surtout des
exhibitions bon il a joué trop bas crocs
mais ce n'était pas tout à fait un vrai
match bon il y avait des partisans mais
aussi des parties rapides là c'est un
vrai tournoi qui compte pour le
classement mondial
et alors il est en tête tu fais bien le
souligner donc c'est un tournoi de
catégorie que catégorie 16 donc un des
tournois vraiment d'élite et karpov qui
n'a pas gagné depuis maintenant très
très longtemps alors peut-être que là
bon il actuellement il est second les
seconds et à un demi point de vue dites
donc qui mène qui mène la danse alors
karpov car pas fait ce que pour une fois
depuis depuis longtemps maintenant
est-ce que karpov et bien va gagner un
tournoi de grande envergure
c'est également quelque chose qu'on
attend tous parce que bon karpov c'est
quelqu'un qui a fait preuve ces derniers
temps un petit peu de manque de
motivation je sais pas ce que tu en
penses tu es fan mais
l'impression que mon karpov s'ils
n'avaient pas tellement envie de jouer
20 du moins envie de gagner et b karpov
perd son titre de champion du monde
il a perdu il n'a pas réussi à imposer
son point de vue
je crois qu'ils en pro c'est d'ailleurs
en procès ils essaient de faire un
procès parce que c'est son gros problème
il a été tout le temps champion du monde
depuis 1975 ou champions ou vice
champion du monde
là il perd tout puisque kasparov est
considéré comme le meilleur joueur du
monde le champion du monde fis des ces
qualifs man car pas besoin tout ça
qu'est-ce que ça devient on sait pas
assez pour ça je pense qu'il ait eu un
coup de blues est donc maintenant il en
train de reprendre les choses en main et
je pense qu'il va essayer de revenir un
peu sur le devant de la scène pour
essayer de continuer sa carrière qui est
loin d'être terminée faut rappeler que
karpov et il n'a que 47 ans je crois à
peu près et que cornouaille fait
toujours dans les vingt premiers
mondiaux aux plus de 60 ans donc il
reste encore de belles années devant
karpov
c'est clair tout à fait clair en ce qui
concerne le tournoi de jaffa donc on a
dit que judit polgar mener la danse
elle mène avec un demi point donc sur le
second qui karpov qu'il ya trois joueurs
qui sont à trois points alors trois
jours qu'ils sont à trois points on a
parlé de la mondialisation du jeu
d'échecs
on peut parler aussi de la nationalité
de ses joueurs on peut parler de la
nationalité de ses joueurs dont karpov
russe polgar endroit on peut parler
également donc de timan qui est
hollandais timone et hollandais je parle
mais dans les trois suivants dans les
trois suivants après paul garret karpov
qui sont des pays connus en fait pour
les échecs la hongrie et la russie
on arrive à une petite surprise tout à
fait donc parlons des trois suivants
donc on a mis l'os brésilien brésilien
regard surprise effectivement c'est vrai
que le brésil n'est pas aujourd'hui n'a
pas cette réputation d'être donc une un
pays dominateur au niveau des échecs et
là ça fait du bien de voir un brésilien
dans un tournoi qui montre les dents et
qui se retrouve à la troisième place
avec d'autres joueurs russes comme cadif
man comme c'est rare ces changements
clés par us airways et american cas on
en retrouve donc un américain est donc
encore en russe kalichman qui est en
embuscade
alors qu'alice man on peut noter qui est
champion du monde qui joue ce champion
du monde qui jouent ils essaient de
demandes
son titre et championne n'est pas
usurpée je crois qu'il l'a démontré
linares il a montré qu'il pouvait jouer
au même niveau que les plus que les 10
meilleurs mondiaux même s'il est un peu
bon il est pas et bien que j'avoue que
j'ai eu quelques craintes quand même
quand elles sont match à briques lego
franchement il a eu du mal c'est vrai
peut-être eu du mal à revenir valliot
sait aussi qu'il avait des problèmes de
paiement alors peut-être ça a joué c'est
un problème de préparation aussi
réparation c'est vrai que derrière il a
quand même bien assurée bon il a bien
assuré et maintenant ils entrent encore
une démontré que bombay fait partie
quand même de de l'élite mondiale et que
peut-être il faudrait ouvrir un peu plus
c'est des tournois on a qu'on a
l'habitude de réserver toujours aux
quatre cinq six meilleurs mondiaux
toujours les mêmes et il démontre qu'il
faudrait peut-être un peu plus ouvrir
parce que c'est pas si clair que ça
c'est vrai c'est vrai alors en ce qui
concerne le classement viennent ensuite
élevé steeman et hadyan tôt et de
joueurs donc moins connus du na wan est
un joueur dont the wind l'eau sur lequel
fine aurez l'occasion de revenir avec
une petite anecdote en ce qui concerne
donc ceux de ce tournoi de de jaffa que
dire de plus stephan
nous allons bientôt présenter ensemble
donc la partie où est la partie du jour
vous avez très jolie partie très
positionnelle très positionnelle ce qui
ce qui est important dans ce tournoi là
c'est qu'effectivement donc judith a
gagné contre team annoncé qu'elle a eu
beaucoup beaucoup de difficultés avec
lui donc là elle a gagné avec les noix
ou derniers tournois précédents dans les
tournois précédant des attentats
précédents donc là une partie
intéressant alors elle a fini contre
timone faut noter aussi que la fée
labatut iman pardon faut faire faut
noter aussi qu'elle a déjà rencontré
karpov et qu'elle a fait nul dans ce qui
est un bon résultat parce que si elle a
déjà fait nul contre le second
il nous reste plus qu'à jouer ceux qui
sont un peu de classement donc a priori
qui sont en moins bonne forme donc elle
est très bien parti pour remporter le
tournoi
moi je te dirai tout de suite j'attends
un match avec une grande impatience
c'est le match karpov kalichman qui n'a
pas encore eu lieu avec celui là à mon
avis il faudra pas louper israêl pic il
sera épique parce que karpov donc
championne déchue va essayer de mettre
un petit peu qualif man au diapason
mécanisme à ne va pas se laisser faire
il va le démontrer que son titre de
champion du monde n'est pas usurpée du
rhdp donc ça risque d'être effectivement
un très bon match donc je crois que
maintenant on a fait le tour à peu près
nicolas je crois de toute petite
anecdote si tu me permets avant de te
laisser poursuivre en ce qui concerne
donc le bas du classement
je n'ai pas parlé donc d'un joueur qui
s'appelle the wind nous tue c'est
l'histoire du bidon c'est quelqu'un qui
tient du million mart us et une région
bien en asie que tu peux épeler son nom
d'un pays uni en mars m y avait même un
air donc et un pays
en asie et aujourd'hui donc ce joueur
est estimée aux alentours de 2630 lots
et finalement
il a un demi point et si on se souvient
bien de tous et de l'histoire je vois
l'exaltation d'un truc et je crois c'est
ça exactement donc on espère tous que ce
joueur va remonter un peu la pointe que
je poursuis pour l'instant c'est pas
terrible c'est pas terrible donc
question penses tu de ce joueur
régis donc ce joueur donc un joueur qui
a un classement qui semble-t-il est
usurpée c'est à dire qu'il a 100 points
ou même 3 300 points des 300 points de
plus que le placement qui démontre dans
ce tournoi est là dans ce tournoi il a
enfin comment il a pu arriver là s'est
trompé et puis ensuite wes on parle pas
de moi un sens c'est quoi bah moi je
pense que ma petite théorie là-dessus
c'est justement c'est cette chose a été
très très très médiatisé donc bon bah
les partis des deux côtés avec leurs
arguments
on m'a alors faites vos preuves c'est
peut-être le message pour l'instant en
tout cas c'est bien parti pour démontrer
qu'il ya eu supercherie l'avenir nous le
dira et nous le confirmera voilà on
verra donc on va passer maintenant à la
deuxième partie donc de notre émission
avec l'analyse de la super party entre
timan et judit polgar
voilà donc on va tout de suite m
l'échiquier en avant on va se mettre
maintenant tout en bas à droite de
l'échiquier je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez suivre la partie avec nous aussi
en cliquant sur jouer avec l'applet java
qui est sur votre droite donc dans
l'émission vous pouvez aussi télécharger
le fichier pgn fichiers pgn qui vous
permet de suivre les parties grâce un
logiciel qui permet de lire les partis
il y en a beaucoup sur internet vous
pouvez faire des recherches mais on peut
vous faciliter les recherches dans la
partie différée de diagonale vous pouvez
télécharger un logiciel qui s'appelle
windows pour les pc ou mac chess je
crois pour les mac et qu'il vous permet
de suivre les parties pgm donc deux
façon pour vous de suivre la partie avec
nous on va là évidemment la suivre en
maintenant en vidéo tout de suite
nicolas avec donc yann timan qui est les
blancs contre judit polgar qu'elle est
noire avec démarrage tout de suite par
le coup cavaliers en f3 alors qu'avec
des f3 c'est vrai que c'est un co qui
paraît un peu étrange on a vu beaucoup
beaucoup de parties précédemment ou bien
les blancs essayé d'entrée de jeu de
mettre un pion au centre alors qu'avait
dit f3 ça peut paraître bizarre je sais
pas ce que tu en penses régis toi
stéphane sont constitués l'horizon s'est
enfin avec ma meilleure expérience
c'est vrai que c'est vrai qu'on a envie
plutôt une impression d'habitude on
envie de mettre un pion sentent marquer
le territoire on prend de l'espace donc
as-tu quelque chose à nous dire
alors je crois que ce qu'on peut dire
là-dessus tout de suite c'est que
d'habitude effectivement on essaie de
jouer soit le pion sur la case de 4 soit
le pion sur la case des 4 c'est un coût
qui en tout cas tout de suite empêche
les noirs eux mêmes de mettre leurs
pions sur la case e 5
voilà voilà ce qu'on peut noter donc
déjà sa limite ses possibilités là et
donc probablement suivant la réponse des
noirs on va pouvoir ensuite voir comment
la partie peut se dérouler il est
possible qu'on puisse continuer avec une
partie avec le pion roi suivant la
réponse prochaine des noirs ce que tu
voulais dire c'est qu'en fait le cas des
f3 of le maximum de flexibilité
voilà c'est une grande flexibilité mais
qui empêche les noirs de jouer le coup
au sein tout de suite quand même
d'accord et puis ça empêche pas de toute
façon dû mettre un pion centre juste
après ça empêche pas de mettre un pion
centre juste après je crois que c'est un
coût qui reste flexible tout à fait
jouable
oublions pas qu il faut sortir les
pièces les cavaliers ont l'avantagé de
pouvoir être sortie avant les fous
puisqu'ils peuvent sauter par dessus des
pions pas besoin de bouger un pion pour
sortir le cavalier c'est critique je
crois que jouer beaucoup six cavaliers
f3 webo cook rami numéro trois mondial
actuel et retrouver un mondial et qui va
bientôt jouer contre kasparov alors
était la nôtre cette ouverture
alors là pas encore de nom orelis
puisqu'on n'est pas encore la position
n'est pas encore suffisamment avancé
pour compte dans mon nom parce que là on
peut transposer actuellement dans pleine
ouverture possible par exemple si les
noirs joué le coup ces sept ans et 5 par
exemple ici oui ce coût pourrait être
suivie par la boue par les blancs par le
coup 2e 2e 4 ici qui transpose aurait
dans une
ouverture sicilienne un exemple voilà de
la loire iations pour cible enfin
revenir à la poêle
voilà on va revenir à partie c'est trop
tôt aujourd'hui pour donner un nom à la
position d'autant plus que les noirs
répondent par le coup symétrique
cavaliers en f 6 finalement les noirs 10
au blanc b tu veux attendre ce que je
jouais moi aussi j'attends donc les deux
joueurs temporise les deux joueurs
temporisant mois à voir la suite tout de
suite parce que le début quand même on
va on va jouer tout de suite alors deux
c4 encore un coup un peu sujet à
discussion quand je regarde cette
position si je comprends bien ce que tu
m'as dit tout à l'heure stéphane bon là
on visiblement le couple lavier seront
empêche les noirs de mettre un pion de 5
voilà cette case aux siens qui cité
interdite pour l'instant puisque le
cavalier blanc ici contrôler la case et
donc le pion ckd bien c'est peut-être
pour empêcher que les noirs met un pion
des cinq effectivement donc le pion de
dessins qui s'ils contrôlent la case des
cinq donc pour l'instant les blancs
essaie d'empêcher des noirs de ces de
s'épandre saut vers le centre e sans
jouer eux mêmes des des coups portés
directement sur le centre c'est des
coups qui contrôle indirectement par les
cases
voilà c'est des coups qui contrôle le
stand à distance puisque pour l'instant
les blancs n'occupe pas aucune les cases
415,4 des quatre pardon case centrale
est occupée par les pièces blanches
donc c'est des coups de contrôle à
distance en maniant d'accord donc on va
voir maintenant un peu genre technique
serpent la tourne effectivement
effectivement c'est un coup
de contournement c'est pas un coup-franc
talent judith continue par un coup
effectivement aussi le contournement le
combler cette v6 avec l'idée de
développer son fou notamment sur la case
bessette où elle contrôlera la grande
diagonale blanche ici que je pointe avec
toutes les cases allumé une très belle
diagonale qui en conjonction avec
lecavalier 6 ici contrôle très bien les
cases blanches donc les noirs on essaye
de contrôler eux-mêmes les cases
blanches centrale de l'échiquier
d'accord donc les noirs effectivement
avec leurs cavaliers essaye de dominer
les cases blanches centrale en rajoutons
un fou effectivement c'est encore une
fois pour ajouter de la pression il ya
peut-être un pion qui viendra en d5
c'est pas un petit peu ce qu'on appelle
l'école hypermoderne essayer de
développer des fois on pioche et au on
est tout à fait l'écho les paires
mondiales kitty tente effectivement de
dire on peut occuper le centre ou de
contrôler à distance dans ce cas là à la
fois les blancs par les coûts c4 et
carla liège 3 contrôle le centre à
distance et les noirs par le coup car et
9,6 et fou 17 qui va venir contrôler le
centre à distance donc 2-2 contrôle de
centres à distance et non pas
d'occupations d'accord en quelque sorte
c'est dominer contrôler le centre
adverse
si jamais les donc la partie adverse
joue quand même le centre cessez
d'affaiblir quelque part ses pions pour
essayer de les prendre peut-être en
finale c'est peut-être quelque chose
comme ça en fait c'est peut-être quelque
chose comme ça en fait on va peut-être
un peu loin on va continuer de voir
l'ouverture à ces deux joueurs
connaissent évidemment très bien ce qui
va suivre donc deux des quatre salles et
maintenant les blancs s'impose au centre
avec le comté 4
hélas les noirs continuent leurs
stratégies de domination de cases
blanches avec le coup donc si ce qui
contrôle la casse des sexes donc on a vu
que lecavalier m6 aussi contrôler cette
case des 5 et aussi la case 4es avec le
fou qui va venir sur le casse bessette
on va encore contrôlé très bien les
cases centrale ici des 5 et leucate ça
permet aussi aux fous sur la case f8 de
se libérer
pouvoir venir soit sur la case b4 soit
éventuellement sur la case de 7 alors
pour les joueurs qui connaissent un
petit peu la théorie d ouverture ici on
a deux possibilités pour
pour dans cette partie finalement soit
transposé dans une sorte de west
indienne ou alors peut-être encore
possibilité de d'avoir une défense
naseaux vit qu'avec un fou en b 4 avec
un foie mais qu'attend on va voir
pourquoi justement ça on va voir le
prochain coup des blancs le coût 4 à 3
justement qui empêche le fou noir de
venir sur cette fameuse carte b4
l'idée étant que les cas les blancs
veulent sortir leur cavalier sur la case
d3 et contrôler les cases e4 et des 5
on a vu qu'il faisait l'objet de la
stratégie des noirs le problème c'est
que s'il est blanc l'avait joué tout de
suite le fou noir serait venu sur cette
case b4 et aurait cloué ce cavalier
puisque le carrier n'aurait pas pu
bouger sous peine d'être en échec par le
roi et donc les noirs auraient empêché
les blancs de contrôler les cases
blanches
donc c'est d'accord c'est toujours un
contrôle en fait un direct plutôt que de
mettre un pion en d5 par exemple un pion
noir directement sur la caisse blanche
j'essaye de contrôler les forces
adverses par des moyens directs
exactement ce que je ressens aussi la de
cette position d'accord alors voyons ce
que ce que les noirs ont joué au foot 17
normal on en avait parlé maintenant les
blancs les noirs pardon contrôle bien
les cases blanches au centre qu'avait
laissé trois de la part des blancs les
blancs ont toujours dans l'idée de
contrôler aussi les cases blanches donc
que les on a deux et deux écoles pour
l'instant de développement qui luttent
pour les mêmes case carte blanche pour
les blancs
carte blanche pour les noirs alors on
connaissait effectivement des ouvertures
un peu plus ouverte où je prends
position au centre j'essaye de me
développer très rapidement je rock
j'essaie d'attaquer soit les dames
soient les lois et puis l'a finalement
que s'apercevoir que tout le début d'une
partie
ça peut jouer sur le contrôle d'une ou
deux cases et c'est ses effectifs des
couleurs de casse surtout des couleurs
de castres est important inversément la
des couleurs mrc de 15 effectivement
comme tu dis registre des couleurs de
cases puisque là c'est bien contrôler on
peut aussi avoir des parties où les
blancs contrôle très bien les cases
blanches et en échange les noirs
contrôler les cases noires et ici la
stratégie des deux camps consiste à
contrôler tous les deux les cases
blanches
c'est quand même assez intéressant parce
qu'il fait pour quelqu'un qui connaît
pas
comme on dira tout de manière
approfondie les échecs c'est vrai que ça
peut paraître bizarre quand même bon les
noirs et les blancs essaye de contrôler
les cases blanches centrale et pourtant
si jamais quelqu'un ne réussit pas dans
cet exercice il y aura un léger
désavantage et ça peut amener c'est pour
amener jusqu'à la perte de la partie le
fait d'avoir perdu le contrôle sur des
cas centrale - tout à fait donc il faut
faire très attention à ça donc là je dis
tu réagis maintenant avec le coût des
cinq qui cette fois est un coût
d'occupation du centre avec le pion des
5 et qui instaure une potentialité des
changes
ici avec le pion c4 alors j'ai une
question à se poser parce que tu nous
dis que depuis tout à l'heure les noirs
essaye de contrôler donc ces cas
centrale indirectement
alors pourquoi maintenant bah pourquoi
maintenant le mettre un pied en d5
alors pourquoi mettre un pion en d5
probablement
justement parce que aujourd'hui le pion
c4 ici peut s'échanger donc il ya une
tension qui s'échangent au centre donc
ya pas blocage l'epa blocage donc ça
reste dynamique
donc les blancs les noirs tout moment
peuvent prendre en c4 ou et blanc prend
dans ses rangs dans des 5 et le contrôle
du fou 17 n'est pas altérée alors que si
les blancs n'avaient pas poussé le pion
c4 le coup de dé 5 aurait bouché
ils auraient buté sur son propre opinion
mais la grâce à cet échange possible la
position sur les cases blanches
président reste dynamique et là
évidemment les blancs peuvent pas
pousser leurs pions c4 c5 qui n'ont eu
perdra un pion sarrail perdre un pion
évidemment puisque régis aussi
fictivement viennent de le signaler
le groupe b 6 ici et le fouet fuite
contrôle parfaitement la case c5 donc
impossible pour les blancs de pousser
donc là c'est les blancs qui choisissent
de faire les changes et la très
important les noir reprennent avec le
cavalier dessin crise alors peut-être tu
peux expliquer pourquoi
peut-être est-ce que tu as un sentiment
d'impuissance pourquoi les noirs comme
ça après sur cette case avec lecavalier
et non pas avec l'option par exemple
dont je n'ai pas c'est vrai que quand on
regarde cette position avec influent
bessette
moi je le dis je je pense que j'aurais
pris du cavalier également parce que si
tu regardes bien régis cette position si
on reprend du piolet le fouillent les
buts sont console en revenant en arrière
si on avait pris ici avec ici le pion
reprenant sur cette case où on verrait
que le fou ici serait complètement
bloqué par son propre pions donc il n'ya
plus d'avenir
tu as fait je n'ai vu ça mais
ce que je prends pas c'est
l'anticipation du cavalier au moment de
la partie donc l'anticipation des
cavaliers de prendre ce pion avec le
cavalier pas parce qu'en fait je pense à
oui parce que tu peux nous dire oui je
comprends ce que tu veux dire que les
noirs ici à montreux reprise possible
ils peuvent prendre du cavalier ils
peuvent prendre du fou ils peuvent
prendre du plomb alors reprendre un peu
du fou déjà alors pourquoi on prend pas
du tout c'est vrai que bon parce que
déjà déjà on a l'habitude de dire que le
fou est un peu plus fort qu'on cavaliers
dans les positions ouvertes dans les
positions ouvertes mais on a du mal à
échanger un fou un début de partie n'ont
pas parce que là elle effectivement le
centre il n'est pas stabilisée l'état de
santé pas stabilisé donc la partie peut
être ouverte
si on donnait le fou tout de suite ce
serait quand même un aveu de faiblesse
et faiblesses puis c'est vrai que le fou
il a quand même mis pas mal de temps
enfin lille on peut très bien prendre
avec le pion finalement mais on obtient
un autre type de partie parce qu'il va
falloir que les noirs a présicé de se
libérer autrement que comme on va le
voir dans cette partie donc on va
peut-être voir la suite ça on s'en
vouloir elle est trop trop loin c'est
vrai que si juste pour expliquer à notre
ami régis est vrai que si les noirs
avaient pris avec le pion il faut bien
qu'il continue à développer et le pion
tu vois comme tu peux le voir en ces 7
tu peux peut-être le marquer d'une case
on est champion ici le pion quittant ses
7 il va bien falloir le bouger pourrait
venir en support à ce pion quittez donc
voilà qui était venu en d5 et là sa
seule case logic ce serait stéphane a
cassé cinq ici et donc on aurait ce
qu'on appelle des pions pendant ce
niveau là arrive un échange avec le pion
des quatre l'émail aurait deux pions
noirs tout seul on a confié aux saintes
qui pourraient faire l'objet de à la
fois de cible et de bélier ses racines
autres partis c'est une autre partie si
notre façon de voir le jeu c'est si
possible aussi il ya des parties sur ce
thème là donc tu vois finalement agi
c'était possible c'était possible donc
cavalier prend finalement
hélas les blancs veulent toujours poussé
le maintenant leurs pions sur la case e
4 ça c'est important et on va voir qui
peuvent pas le faire tout de suite parce
que si les blancs veulent faire ça parce
qu'ils veulent libérer leurs fous et ils
veulent aussi ne pas empêcher le foot
ici de pouvoir s'émanciper sur cette
diagonale donc ils veulent pousser le
pion à 24 malheureusement si le fond
tout de suite après la prise des noirs
ici sur la casse ces trois la reprise du
pion le fou de cette ici prendrait le
pion e4 donc c'est pas possible pour
l'instant pour les blancs de jouer eux
quatre tout de suite c'est pour ça que
les blancs jouent au coup suivant le
coup cette dame en c2 qui contrôlent
maintenant la case e 4 qui va permettre
donc le compte d'apple voilà d'appuyer
effectivement continue régis d'appuyer
la poussée de ce pion donc ça fait
bientôt nous en sommes qu qu'au septième
coup il ça fait presque six coups de
part et d'autre que du joueur joue
contre cette case des 5es à quatre
arrêts tout à fait donc c'est vrai c'est
là qu'on voit que les stratégies démarre
dès les premiers comme quoi une case
c'est quelque chose d'important échec
une casser quelque chose de fondamental
alors judith anticipent cette montée de
parce que c'est de toute façon quand les
blancs vont pousser les rangs 4 ce
cavalier n'aura pas d'autre choix
raisonnable que le s'échanger contre le
cavaly c3 donc ils préfèrent elles
préfèrent le faire je crois tout de
suite on va le voir voilà qu'avec des
princes et rois
évidemment les blancs reprennent avec le
pion ce b pourquoi parce qu'on ramène un
pion vers le centre donc on contrôle
bien le pion des quatre et on garde
d'annoncer deux parce qu'on veut compte
toujours contrôler la case 4 pour
pouvoir envahir le centre avec les
viandes ont finalement les blancs une
stratégie maintenant d'occupation du
centre
je me suis peut également la question
pourquoi les blancs vers près du pion et
parle pas de la dame
quand même si si les plus il est blanc
auprès de la ddt de la dame
ils attaquent quand même le pion qui ans
et 7 ans le pion qui étend ses sept
peut-être un pion en rire et je me
trompe
non tu te trompe puisque se fiancer 7
ici peut très bien aller sur le cac
c'est 500 problème puisqu'il est protégé
à la fois par b6 et par leproux et suit
donc il n'est pas arriérés du tout c'est
un pion qui est potentiellement
dangereux c'est un espèce de ressort
mais quand même falloir jouer tôt ou
tard d'ailleurs les normes vont devoir
le jetons tard parce qu'il faut pas
garder ses pions sur les arrières il
faut bien les faire ressortir pour
attaquer l'adversaire d'accord donc pas
possible d'empêcher le coup de
libération des noirs c5
oui donc
constituer un duo c3 et des quatre pour
garder à la fin un pur au centre
exactement
donc après le coup fawcett les blancs
envahi se sentent qu'on me le dire
et ensuite vient le temps pour les noirs
de mettre le roi à l'abri petit rock ça
y est ils ont presque fini leur
développement ils restent plus que
lecavalier ambiguïté à jouer et ils ont
presque terminé leur développement reste
aux blancs aussi à terminer leur
développement ce qui ce qui est
important c'est qu'ils étaient eux
ce qui est important c'est ce qui est
également important de noter justement
par rapport à l'école moderne que tu as
très bien présenté tout à l'heure on a
l'habitude de développer d'abord les
cavaliers ensuite les fous etc
hélas quand on regarde cette position le
cavalier des noirs n'a pas encore bougé
de la partie effectivement donc c'est
une autre une autre conception de la
partie qui est fait part jeudi paul
guérin finalement et qui nous dit qu'il
ne sert à rien d'avoir des préjugés aux
échecs puisque finalement ça tue un peu
la créativité il vaut mieux penser par
rapport à un plan et son propre plan
comme on dit vaut mieux même s'il bon
effectivement et le plein des noirs
c'est bien de jouer c'est cette c5 pour
essayer d'échanger ici au centre afin
d'affaiblir un petit peu ce centre pour
pouvoir le contre-attaqué ultérieurement
et on va voir que c'est ça qui va se
passer d'accord donc là j'ai donné la
grande ligne de la partie alors après
fou des trois coups logique on sort le
fou on se protège depuis en quatre avec
la dame et le fou en batterie donc que
maintenant la dame est libre et libre de
ce pouvoir se déplacer le pian 4 bien
protégé parce qu'il faut pas oublier
qu'il est toujours sur la menace de ce
fou ici le fourbe et cette ville il faut
faire très attention aux petites
questions tout à l'heure tu sais que le
foot buté sur son pion dans l'exemple de
total l on est tout à fait mais hélas le
fait de multiplier par 2 donc de mettre
un fouet une dame est ce que finalement
la dame est pas buter contre le fou
effectivement la dame est buté contre le
fou mais dans ce cas là on appelle ça
une batterie
on appelle ça une batterie parce que si
le pion ici blanc ça pouvait s'avancer
en créant une menace sur la case de 5
le fou ici protégé par la dame n'est
protégé par la dame pourrait venir
prendre le pian h7 d'accord donc là
c'est plutôt un espèce de batteries
ressort un evs mais effectivement
pourrait penser aussi que le fourn pêche
la dame de bouger
on est dans une pièce de lourdes le
pitch lourdes le ps tourne à vocation à
être derrière ces pièces légères un
petit peu comme dans l'armée on met
d'abord les fantassins devant et
derrière l'artillerie d'accord
l'artillerie est derrière pour pour être
en support des fantassins qu'il avance
d'accord il ya quelque chose que je
remarque également dans cette position
effectivement derrière le rideau des
pions blancs
on voit les pièces se développer je dire
avec aisance et confortablement il ya la
dame le fou le cavalier protégé par le
par les pions blancs et quand on regarde
les cons noir fini les pièces sont
uniquement sur la 7ème fin sur les deux
premiers ranger oui c'est vrai et
effectivement il va falloir que les
noirs réagissent tôt ou tard pour contre
attaquer parce qu'il manque d'espacé une
langue n'est ce pas cela on va dire que
les blancs ont gagné pour l'instant plus
d'espacé que les noirs mais on va voir
comment judith justement va essayer de
contre attaquer c'est ce problème
d'accord mais c'est bien de noter qu
effectivement il ya d'un côté un
davantage d'espacé et de l'autre - des
espaces et surtout contrôle du centre à
distance pour l'instant c'est vrai que
moi là je vois un centre blanquer très
très fort je vois des pièces blanches
qui s'activent et les noirs qui sont un
peu resserré sur eux mêmes et il faut
réagir
il faut réagir il faut réagir et tout de
suite cavaliers lecavalier pas encore
100 km à développer le cavalier pas
encore quand il est tout de suite avant
de sortir son cavalier judith il réagit
par à part le fameux coup de libération
dont on parle et c5
l'idée pour les noirs ça va être des
salles de s'échanger ici contre le pion
des quatre libérer une colonne ici pour
une tour peut-être maintenant après le
pion des 4 va être tout seul une fois
que les changes sera fait donc sera
sujet aussi à être attaqué par les
pièces noires ce que tu en train de nous
dire c'est qu'on va passer d'un centre
blanqui très fort à un centre qui va
être un peu plus faible un peu plus
faible on être toujours à fort potentiel
de gain de trois points en 2 3 vous
effectivement c'est très simple à skull
là vraiment ça bascule vraiment
effectivement c'est une contre attaque
qui est fondamental dans cette position
il faut pas laisser les blancs
s'installer durablement au centre alors
on voit la suite petit rock pour les
blancs il était temps il faut bien
rock'n moment donné et là un petit coup
subtil de judith qui a noté à une
subtilité dans la position d'avancé 8
alors simple commenté un petit peu ce
coup le nicolas la menace des noirs ici
c'est de prendre sur la casse des quatre
parce que une fois que les blancs en
reprendront du pion c3 et judith n'aura
aucun scrupule à échanger les dames
parce qu'on sait qu'avec un centre fort
il faut garder les dames sur l'échiquier
pour que nos amis
donc spectateur comprenne bien c'est
vrai que c'est l'intérêt de la position
des blancs telle que je la comprends
c'est c'est d'attaquer ils ont centre un
centre c'est fait pour avancer pour
gêner les pièces adverse
donc s'il ya encore des dames si encore
pas mal de pièces quand j'ai avancé un
pion blanc au centre sava chasser une
par exemple une pièce défensive et je
vais ramener encore des pièces à
l'attaqué c'est peut-être ce qui va
faire la différence les glandes pas
intérêt à échanger des plaids et des
pièces quand ils ont un centre de pions
fort ça c'est une règle je pense qu'on
peut dicter ce soir je pense qu on y
reviendra tout à l'heure puisqu'il ya
plusieurs thèmes comme le la majorité
sur l'ale dames où les majorités
jo était temps d'avoir aussi les idées
de judith alors c'est pour ça que liane
10 mhadjou le coût d'1 2 2 c'est pour
empêcher cette fameuse ce fameux échange
de dames alors maintenant je lui dis tu
joues le coup ce qui est caché en fait
qui était caché derrière ce coup
d'hommes s'est vite qui menaçait de
prendre des quatre mais il maintenant il
ya le coup fou à 6 et voilà je lui dit
qu'on le disait maintenant le travail du
fou est terminée parce que ce point 4 et
très bien défendue à la fois par le
fruit par l'adam donc maintenant je dis
tu vas essayer d'échanger un maximum de
pièces
toujours dans l'idée d'arriver dans une
sorte de finale où le faible nombre de
pièces augmenterait un avantage des
noirs ce qui aurait pu d'attac pour les
blancs et il y aurait plus qu'un
avantage pour les noirs et puis ils
disent que j'aille voir à la fin
effectivement un pion des 4 une fois que
les changes sera fait par le pion c5 et
des quatre pions des quatre qui sera
tout seul qui pourrait donc être attaqué
par une tour par exemple la tour et
suites qui pourraient venir sur la case
des huit attaqué ce pion qui serait donc
en danger et il ya aussi le fait que les
pions les noirs aurait une majorité ce
qu'on appelle une majorité à la dame
avec un pion à cette époque yongle 6
contre un seul pion en a trois donc un
pion passé potentiel pour les noirs
allèles dames et qu'on aura l'occasion
de ré expliquer un petit peu plus tard
dans la partie
effectivement alors maintenant rial
continue son développement avec le
coutour d1
il commence à se prémunir et à bien
protéger son pion des quatre parce qu'il
sent que lille est sous pression soutien
des 4 gr cause du pion c5 et judith elle
continue son idée d'échangé au maximum
de pièces dont comprend d'avoir en d4
est là bien entendu il n'était pas
intéressant pour les blancs d
j'ai le fou qui était donc tout en haut
à gauche on assiste maintenant parce que
ça aurait permis au noir de sortir leur
pièce même coup franc à six ans ne
reflètent peut-être d'un emprunt à 6 ou
cavaliers prend 1,6 et on a ressorti ses
pièces accélérant le développement des
noirs accélérant ne le plains des noirs
tout à fait donc là maintenant judith
choisi de prendre des 4 après pions
prend des 4 l échange d'une paire de fou
d'en prendre des trois est maintenant
d'un à six je dis tu n'as pas toujours
peur à les protéger par son cavalier ici
qui protège très bien la dame elle n'a
pas peur de changer les dames c'est son
but puisque moi il ya deux pièces sur
l'échiquier - le cintre blanc à
d'importance alors c'est assez
remarquable parce que lecavalier compte
justement consisté tout à l'heure qui
n'avait pas bougé depuis le départ de la
partie depuis le début de la partie
finalement il sert très bien donner sur
la case oui des puisque il a à la fois
protéger le fouet et maintenant ils
protègent la dame effectivement c'est
judith la ramenait lé tout est là la
régie a activé son cavalier sur sa case
initiale à utiliser le potentiel maximal
de toutes ces pièces effectivement on
peut dire ça on peut dire qu'elle a
maximisé sahel a bien fait de retarder
le développement de son cavalier
après maintenant foulée deux derniers
coups de développement des blancs ça y
est les tours sans connexion important
de connecter les tours aux échecs
les tours sont protégés l'une par
l'autre le fond de données bien placé il
protège le fameux pions des caps dont on
a dit qu'ils pouvaient s'avérer faible
pour l'instant ce pion des quatre archi
protéger on peut noter que les blancs le
protège aussi par la dame par la tour
qui en d1 et aussi par le cavalier qui
en f3 donc on voit bien que c'est un
point important de la position blanche
il est surprotégé donc on a d'un côté un
avantage qui sera je pense grandissant
si les pièces échange donc pour les
noirs d'un côté on a les blancs qui ont
un avantage quand même de développement
certain puisque le cavalier noir là il
n'est pas développé wimille un coût de
développement il est pas très important
ce retard de développement
l'ailé tout rond
la tour est déjà développé et côté des
noirs les taux n'ont pas encore bougé de
l'organisme mise à part le rock
alors on va voir maintenant ce qui se
passe donc judith échanges mais comme
elle avait changé le fou maintenant les
changes la dame pour prendre des trois
et ça y est maintenant elle sort son
cavalier sur la case 17 elle a aussi
circulé mais voilà exactement comme tu
dit régis il ne servait plus à rien là
où il faut habituer actuellement le
mettre en jeu et on peut noter que
maintenant le pion e4 ici pour les
blancs est faible donc la case naturel
pour le cavalier c'est de venir sur la
case f6 attaquant le pion faible de la
part des blancs ce pion faible qu'il y
aura du mal on va le voir pourquoi
ensuite à avancer on verra pourquoi pour
quelle raison et on pourra noter aussi
que les tours blanc les tournois elles
aussi sont connectés d'accord donc en
fait la colonne c'est finalement un
appartient on peut pas dire qu'elle
appartient aux blancs ou alors
effectivement tube ou note interne dans
la partie la colonne s'est il va falloir
savoir ce qui va se passer dans cette
colonne effectivement quand tu gagnes
colonne ouverte et nicolas il faut
l'occuper le plus vite possible on a
envie d'y mettre une tour qui explose
régissant une forcément et c'est
d'ailleurs le coup qu'a choisi timan
tout de suite le coutour c1
voilà ça y est qui occupe cette fameuse
colonne il faut éviter pour les noirs
que il ya une pression trop grande qui
s'exerce sur cette colonne ouverte parce
que c'est un chemin d'invasion du camp
adverse
je crois que d'ailleurs que ce coût
était quasiment
obligé pour les blancs puisque si jamais
c'était pas les blancs qui avait fait
fait ce coup je pense que c'est les
noirs calais non j'aurais fait sans
scrupules et l'article il aurait été
beaucoup plus difficile pour les blancs
après de contre attaquer cette colonne
effectivement alors il faut petit repli
question comme vous savez je suis suite
à ces débutants vous parlez donc
d'investir la colonne c'est oui lajouane
une ligne une rangée vide
la ligne 5 effectivement cette ligne là
est ce que donnait de même est ce que la
tour leur faim ne peut pas la prendre
mais est ce que cette rangée est
important c'est moins important alors
pourquoi pourquoi cette rangée moins
importante que d'avoir cette rangée là
on parlait de on parler d'eux en fait on
veut contrôler la coloniser pourra
régner sur cette rangée parce que sur ce
étrangers là la 7e il ya beaucoup de
pièces donc en fait on peut ramasser des
pièces au passage alors que sur cette
rangée là ici c'est pas très intéressant
de l'occuper parce qu'on pourrait
ramasser ya pas de pièces emprise ya
rien imagine un petit peu régissent la
position avec une tour blanche omb et 7
je te demanderai de souligner les cas
stéphane une fleur blanche en b 7e tour
blanche sur le cac baisse est que jamais
mais une tour blanche sur la casse c'est
cette peinture blanche sur la casser
cette image in la même position avec les
deux tours ici
j'imagine un peu la force la force de
ses tours puisque les tours sont auto
protéger on est d'accord et on pourrait
prendre le cavalier prendre le fou
peut-être prendre le pion après prendre
le pion prendre le pion elle pourrait
prendre toutes les pièces d'accord aussi
saisie c'est un thème tactique qui
revient souvent prendre la 7e ou la
deuxième rangée est souvent un facteur
déterminant sur les avantages d'un
fonctionnement qu'on accélère maintenant
la partie
après tours fc 8 puisque les noirs
évidemment empêche les blancs d'avoir
une trop grosse pression par les deux
tours il faut absolument échanger une
perte de tours tous tes en c3 et judith
continue sa stratégie d' échange de
pièces pour penser 3 est maintenant
quatrième si ça y est le pion aux quatre
été attaqué alors on peut noter tout de
suite nicolas que sans ce pion avance
sur la case e5 lecavalier bondir et sur
la case des 5 avec une case fantastique
puisque c'est la case une case
dont on a déjà parlé pour une partie
d'adams d'ailleurs je prends une partie
de michael adams qui avait formé fort
joliment gagner ça serait une classe
fantastique pour un cavalier c'est vrai
que pour un débutant je pense qu'il est
on a presque envie bond le plus on est
attaqué je peux l'avant c'est en
attaquant une pièce adverse c'est vrai
qu'on a envie de l'avancé ce pion mais
le cavaly serait trop fort puisqu'il n'y
a plus de foule il ya plus de sous deux
cases blanches pour le pour l'échanger
pour les blancs et il ya plus de pions
après qui pourraient l'attaqué donc ce
cavalli serait indélogeable est très
fort et le fou qui tu as en b2 et le fac
et en b2 il devenait très mauvais
puisqu'ils lutterait contre son propre
pion qui n'aurait plus l'espoir
d'avancées donc il faut absolument que
les blancs empêche cette possibilité il
faut qu'il garde la souplesse de leur
centre de pions donc il faut qu'ils
protègent leurs pions en quatre mots qui
protègent leurs pions 4 c'est pour ça
que les blancs jouent le coup cavaliers
en d2 et maintenant je dis tu joues un
coup un peu curieux le coup b5 21e coup
et ça c'est la clé la position je dis tu
as trouvé une manoeuvre régis qui
fait office de deux en fait de mettre un
majorité sa majorité elle elle dame
c'est vrai bon pour que tu comprennes
bien bien cette position régis en fait
le plan b s'inquiète un plan qui est qui
est vraiment standard dans cette
position alors l'idée l'idée est double
on peut à la fois jouer à cette a5 et
ensuite des cinq b4 secret champion
passé qui peut être très fort et ça peut
être aussi une possibilité pour le câble
et noir de revenir sur la case 17 pour
après l'avancé pour après avancé
effectivement mais c'est b6 et sur
l'éventuelle mans sur la case c4 juste
pour que tu comprennes bien un registre
dans cette position si on enlevait
toutes les pièces les noirs aurait un
avantage gagnant les noms revenant match
gagnant puisqu'il aurait deux pieds en
contre sur les dames donc un pion passé
éloigné éloignés et s'éloigner s'il a
changé d'âme
voilà on n'échange que toutes les pièces
on la veut dire que pour pouvoir arrêter
ce pion éloigner les blancs devraient
ramener le roi mais comme il est
beaucoup plus loin que récemment que
l'homologue noire s'étend en terme
d'occasions
voilà abandonné le roi noir pour aller
de l'autre côté croquer les conquêtes
procurer tous les autres plans pendant
que le roi blanc s'occuper la série de
jeux d'échecs ce département
effectivement ce serait celle justement
ce à l'image est très très bon et c'est
tout jeu d'échec c'est du fat man qui
sait si des prises de pions le roi voilà
quand le pape main comme le jeu pacman
très belles images c'est une jolie image
résiste donc la régente en plus dit
judith affiche clairement le plan de la
position je joue le pion de ma majorité
je la vends ce pour créer un pion passé
alors voyons les coups suivants
maintenant tour ses six pour les blancs
donc les blancs essayé d'envahir un
petit peu le camp noir
alors on peut se demander il y aurait
peut-être plus je le tour c'est 7 mai
sur le coutour c7 latour ans et 7 les
oies les noirs simplement jouer les
courroies et fuite puis ensuite 3,8 et
après le roi serait venu embêter la tour
sur la casse dès 8 ans gagnant des temps
sur l'être en gagnant des temps sur la
tour donc ce n'était pas forcément la
meilleure solution pour les blancs donc
elle préfère mettre de suite la tour sur
la casse qui lui semble enfin il peut
faire ils préfèrent pardon mètres la
tour sur laquelle est la meilleure pour
lui tout à fait et d'ailleurs les noirs
anticiper l'arrivée de la tour a enjoint
roi et fuite
il ramène le roi maintenant vers le
centre une fois que la cette tour a
disparu le roi maintenant peuvent
s'activer vers le centre maintenant les
blancs jouent le coup à f3 qui protège
le pion de 4 donc libère le cavalier de
sa défense donc ça va permettre d'autres
à ce cavalier de bouger parce que pour
l'instant il était viré à la défense de
ce piano 4 mains tenant roi 8 jeudi de
continuer d'amener son roi vers le
centre l'idée peut-être amené le roi sur
la place des sept où ils chassent que la
tour à tour lewis aurait excellemment
placé vers le centre alors tu vois j
sais à qui tu important de de voir dans
cette position c'est que les dames se
sont échangées et donc le roi est bien
commence à prendre un rôle très
important et c'est pour ça que les rois
de parts et d'autres vont vont se
rapprocher notamment le roi noir regarde
c'est une pièce d'attac en finale et là
on est presque en finale donc judith
ramène le roi donc en finale c'est quand
il a évidemment le moins de place
possible sur l'échiquier donc maintenant
timan peut activer son cavalier sur la
case d3 donc la position est toujours
équilibré à ce moment là et la judith
choisissent de jouer cavalier 17
lecavalier a rempli son office
il a obligé les blancs à perdre des
temps avec le coup cavaliers en d2 suivi
de f3 il va maintenant essayer d'envahir
le camp blanc par la case b6 et la case
c4 donc on comprend mieux le coup b5
maintenant donc le cavalier qui est un
bel 8 est venu en 17 puis on réussisse
il revient en décèdent pour partir en b
si c'est léon sur la casse et catherine
ont passé c'est vrai c'est tout tourne
autour d'une table et oui c'est au tour
du cavalier tout autour de moi comme on
peut dire ça à vrai ballet régie c'est
un ballet le ballet du cavalier donc
c'est presque musicale
tout tourne autour de ça va donc qui est
un des thèmes de 2,2 à l'endroit de
telle musique voilà que non c'est pour
ça que je lui en parler parce qu'il ya
une musique de régis qui parle de ben
ali dont croit f1 cavaliers en b6
cavalli c5 et c'est important puisque
maintenant la menace des noirs était de
venir sur le cas ces quatre attaquants
la fois le fou en a trois et le pion le
four b2 pardon et le pion à trois qui on
a trois qui étaient sous le feu du fou
adverse du fou hausse est donc le quart
et les c5 intercepte pardon alors
attention il faut que je revienne en
arrière voilà le cavalier en c5
intercepte
la double menace potentielle des noirs
effectivement ça empêche par les nord de
jeu cavaliers en c4 le fou noir est
attaqué et là ça y est on peut
considérer que judith a réussi son plan
et on va voir que judith maintenant a
pris un petit avantage dans la position
parce que les noms et les blancs
beaucoup de problèmes le cavalier
attaque à la fois le fou le pion en a
trois et on va voir que ce fou contrôler
aussi le pion en d4
donc ce pion des 4 va s'avérer
maintenant une faiblesse pour les blancs
on avait l'impression et tu pourras
peut-être me confirmé régis on avait
l'impression que les blancs étaient
plutôt pas mal commencé à pénétrer le
camp des noirs et puis avec un petit
coup de cavaliers deux trois petits
coups de cavaliers bien placé si ça
passe la position bascule et finalement
les pièces blanches bas sont pas si bien
placé que ça effectivement elles sont
pas si bien placé que ça on va voir
pourquoi après phocéen et tour des vite
on veut que ça y est les blancs ne
peuvent plus protéger efficacement leurs
pions des quatre on voit que le seul
coup pour protéger ce serait de revenir
en arrière avec le cavalier que la
retraite de ray ban et la retraite est
jamais bon et c'est là sa paire un pion
et sa péremption puisque le fou aux sept
attaquerez le pion à trois avec le
cavalier en protection donc gagnant un
pion donc on voit que ça y est les noirs
ont réussi à inverser la position il est
noir
judith a réussi et à ce moment là de la
partie j'ai vérifié avec le logiciel un
logiciel de jeu d'échecs
judith a joué parfaitement les coups
comme si c'était un ordinateur et bien
c'est vrai que c'est chic quand même
vraiment impressionner par quelques
coups de cavaliers arriver à un tel
avantage alors que les ont l'impression
que les blancs gigoter dans leur camp
elle a trouvé les coups juste les coups
parfaits
découvre tellement simple aussi eh bien
on va le voir tout de suite et il faut
qu'on déroule les coûts maintenant tu
mènes essai de compliquer la position en
jour le coup à 4 ils essaient dé changer
ce pion b5 parce qu'il a perdu parce
qu'il est perdu il essaie de compliqué
effectivement en maintenant il a vu
qu'il avait perdu le combat stratégique
ils essaient de compliquer la position
mais après je vous dis tu as tout
calculer et on va voir comment ça se
déroule tout reprendre et 4 et après
cavalli b3 tour des 3 ça y est les
blancs un problème insoluble parce que
le fabuleux pour effectivement quand tu
dit régis puisque le car il est attaqué
et si lecavalier bouge
imaginons qu'il revienne sur la casse
c'est sec le coup fatal tour d un échec
est roi et ça paye sa perle sa paire le
fou donc là les noirs vont gagner une
pièce c'est fini il n'y a rien à faire
on va voir que les blancs vont essayer
de s'en sortir mais on va voir qui s'en
sortent pas à vouloir protéger un pion
mais les bleus ont perdu une pièce voilà
donc finalement ils ont calculé qu'il
pouvait pas s'en sortir donc apprendre
b5 l'idée c'est que maintenant si les
noirs prennent le cavalier évidemment la
tour pour reprendre cavaliers en c5 mais
judith a vu plus loin
cavalier maintenant tout de suite car
elle est sur la case e 5 avec le double
avantage d'attaquer la tour et on garde
la menace attaqué le cavalier et si
lecavalier bouge en gare de la menace
tour en d1 échec au roi qui attaquent le
foot c'est un
donc on voit que là ça y est celui-là a
gagné la partie
on a longtemps parlé largement parlait
justement de comment dire de la faculté
tactique d
dita justement renversé des positions a
amené son adversaire depuis l'arrêt
complet la même pas renverser voit que
c'est une partie de linéaire elle a
parfaitement joué positionnement cette
partie mais à la fin quand même quelques
et le brio tactique un tel brio
patinoire et ce n'est pas fini on va
voir la fin quand même à la seconde tout
à fait fini entre nous c'est stéphane
alors timone essaie de se débattre un
petit peu tour ses huit échecs roi des
sept tours à huit il va essayer de
ramasser encore un pion parce qu'il se
dit bon mais je vais perdre une pièce
mais je vais peut-être aussi d'en sortir
d'accord tu veux nous dire qu'avec un
pièce en moins mais un pion de plus
simple que de tenir ni encore là il y
croit encore parce qu'il a encore un
petit pion en bessin et s'il arrive à
prendre le pion à 7 et que ce pion des
scènes peu avancé il peut peut-être
récupérer la pièce peut-être les noirs
sont obligés de sacrifier une pièce pour
ce pion donc il y croit encore un petit
peu
donc là je dit elle ne fait pas d'état
d'âme tout reprend cavaliers tout
reprendra cet échec 3 3 8 et la
brillante immense se rend compte qu'il a
perdu la partie pourquoi parce que si
y'a un team protège son champion en
jaune pour b 7 donc le pion ici serait
protégé et b les noirs jour et le coup
tourbe et un attaquant
ici le fou c'est un obligerait les
blancs à mettre la tour sur la case ses
sept pour protéger le fou hélas le coup
cavaliers en d3 attaquerez le fou cloud
et puisque le roi ici derrière il peut
pas le fou ne peut pas bouger quand les
trois qu'il gagnerait encore le fou donc
là les blancs sont obligés de jouer le
coutour à 1 pour éviter cette débâcle
et après tout reprend b52 noire les
noirs est avec une pièce de plus à ce
niveau là de la compétition et intime
and ancien vice-champion du monde sait
très bien que même une joueuse de
laquelle un joueur de la classe de judit
polgar ne peut pas ne peut rater le gain
aussi facilement c'est vrai que régis
peut-être toi quantique une pièce de moi
peut-être que tu aurions envie de
continuer la partie mais bon c'est vrai
qu'à ce niveau là je pense qu'il ya un
respect qui se fait bon la partie comme
on dit souvent l'anecdote amusante
il vaut mieux une fin sans souffrance
une souffrance sans fin
voilà exactement exactement c'est je
crois que c'est je crois que c'est pour
ça que tillman a préféré abandonner
judic pas la peine de continuer de
galère autant arrêter le désastre et
puis et puis entré chez soi exactement
je crois que là nicolas pour cette
partie c'est tout à fait exact
donc là judit polgar très belle partie
donc devant yann timan on va passer
maintenant à la troisième donc partie de
notre émission avec un retour sur
l'actualité de la semaine l'actualité de
la semaine
blanc donc tout de suite nicolas je
crois que on va parler avant de parler
de la qualité de la semaine dont il ya
le match 4 chefs pickpockets ya le grand
prix du sénat il ya pas mal de pas mal
de choses il y analyse qui est là et qui
fait sa musique et sa muse y sera
présent au sénat on peut bien tu peux
nous on peut noter risque fait quel
effet ça te fait d'avoir ta musique
jouait au sénat je suis très très
heureux très heureux de l'entente gros
cenal line vraiment très heureux alors
je crois nicolas rina palamède le
reconnais je crois qu'il ya deux choses
il me semble que tu as un bon un projet
qui est clair qu'il va bientôt bientôt
arriver qui est un concert que tu vas
bientôt donner je peux en parler
il se conserve effectivement donc je
donne un concert avec un band qui me
suit depuis depuis le départ donc zappé
le belledonne bande et nous donnant un
concert en fait aux à l'espace donnell
dans le 6e arrondissement et ça sera le
samedi 20 mai à 20h30
c'était super métro odéon pour rappel
l'adresse exacte wallace et au 8 rue de
nesle et l'entrée le tarif est de 80
francs et 60 francs pour les ans prix
réduit il me semble que tu as également
un site internet où on peut écouter je
crois ta musique la télécharger
exactement oui alors je j'ai des sites
fillier notamment français mais je crois
que tu peux donner carrément le nom de
ton site puisque après on peut toujours
trouver voilà voilà donc cw trois fois
point vaut glen prod.com van goolen
prod.com sur ce site on peut télécharger
certains morceaux de ta musique
on peut avoir toute l'information sur
ton spectacle voilà et donc toutes les
informations que les interventions de
suivre là tout est retrouvé dans ce site
avec également l'egypte pour le cinéma
également donc tout est dedans alors
autre projet sophie j'ai eu l'occasion
je peux dire aux téléspectateurs j'ai eu
l'occasion d'écouter sa musique c'est
vraiment impressionnant
alors je crois que tu as également une
idée on peut pas peut-être pas encore
parlé de projets mais je sais que tu
quelque chose qui trotte dans sa tête
c'est par rapport aux échecs notamment
effectivement tu utilises quand même lié
également moselle
pas par hasard que tu me lis cette
émission et que tu viennes à cette
émission
effectivement donc il ya plus d'un an
une vision m'est apparu donc nous sommes
en train de jeudi nous parce qu on est
plusieurs sur sur cette histoire donc de
faire un système pour permettre à chaque
partie d'abord étant unique chaque parti
lui serait attribué une mélodie et de
souhaite donc pouvoir retrouver des
parties célèbres ou moins célèbres par
l'air qui lui est associée et tu penses
tu penses tu qu'une belle partie des
parties tu sais où il beaucoup beaucoup
d'émotion que 7ème ou s'il doit se
traduire non seulement elle va se
traduire mais je pense que la symbiose
va être magique c'est à dire qu'à une
belle partie j'espère ne pas me tromper
mais j'espère qu'elle a la belle partie
du sera attribué une belle mélodie et
ben écoute chez attend avec impatience
hui je suis preneur aussi je suis une
base de partie très intéressante que
j'aimerais bien mettre en musique
c'est un système que tu vas mettre au
point et permettra automatiquement de
trouver une mélodie sur une partie
d'échecs
exactement donc voilà donc on peut
parler d'un beau projet sa part ça peut
me rappeler le
le système de cocktails cancer de bon si
je crois que c'est un système cac a noté
jacques rosselin le président de canal
web et donc qui te soutiennent dans
cette démarche qui me soutiendront
alors on va en revenir à l'actualité de
la semaine nicolas très rapidement le
match 4 chefs pic est finalement match
nul alors que quatre chefs avaient pris
l'ascendant
vraiment c'était un match
d'allers-retours ya piqué qui commence à
prendre l'aventage qui gagne contre
contre donc notre ami vladislav tkachiev
ensuite donc vlad arrive à égaliser où
elle prend l'avantagé
on se dit bon bah là d'un avantage
psychologique avant sa septième partie
est loin derrière
il a les blancs ils allaient blanc est
hyper content repiquer quand même erreur
et il perd alors qu'ils avaient
davantage
il avait dans une contre tours et
cavaliers je crois et donc c'est
vraiment dommage mais c'est quand même
un match nul prometteur puisque piquette
avait battu kasparov quoi il ya moi nuit
effectivement au grand prix kasparov
donc on se dit les bas quand même
vladislav est en train de prendre de
l'ampleur j'ai l'impression que les
matchs vont aller en crescendo et que
les prochains événements les prochains
matches à cannes alors quand être
également très intéressant par contre le
dise l'arc a fait un petit faux pas
puisqu'il n'a pas réussi à se qualifier
pour la finale du grand prix de bordeaux
il a trébuché devant notre grand jeu
contre notre joël lautier nationale
avant
joël n'est pas non plus le dernier venu
et effectivement il s'est laissé
surprendre et puis en deuxième partie
n'a rien pu faire contre joël qui avec
les blancs étaient trop trop solide et
l'a perdue cruellement quand même penser
peut-être une bonne transition puisque
on va retrouver donc joël lautier au
grand prix du sénat leur fameux grand
prix du sénat on va retrouver quelqu'un
que tu connais bien aussi régis alexei
shirov oui oui je les connais je l'avais
dit à l'émission précédente déjà failli
quelque temps oui effectivement j'ai
connu à bordeaux est quelqu'un de très
long et très bien donc le quatrième
joueur mondial sera au sénat on va
retrouver alors là ça fait longtemps
qu'on a pas vu jouer ça fait très
longtemps et c'est peut-être une de ses
dernières apparitions l'élection pion du
monde d'exception depuis la légende
vivante boris spassky celui qui a joué
contre fischer en 72 le match du siècle
il sera là il sort au sénat donc à ne
pas rater
au palmarès qui sera l'aacm dingue et
reste donc notre coup de coeur c'est le
petit arnaud charge les le petit parce
qu'il est quand lorsque m il est grand
maître virtuellement puisque salle il a
réussi ses trois dents il a réussi ses
trois normes et c'est effectivement très
très récent donc on a eu l'occasion de
rencontrer leurs nous il n'ya pas très
longtemps
quel plaisir de voir arnaud enfin à
tenir sa troisième normes après avoir
l'avoir si longtemps cherché si
longtemps cherché donc mon verdict est
très dangereux il d'autant plus dans le
trou et arnaud hauchard que les
positions sont simples donc il va
chercher lui avoir simplifié exposition
le maximum et avoir des positions où il
est où son génie
je dirais intuitif dans les positions
simple pourra s'exprimer c'est un peu
notre laurent frayssinet 10 grand prix
de bordeaux facilement devant dont on
espère qu'il le fera un peu mieux que
laurent laurent qu'il qu'elle fait de
belles parties très belle partie mais
qui n'a malheureusement pas réussi à
passer l'obstacle mais là peut-être
arnaud ouradou possibilité puisque il
s'est hissé prépare je sais tu as eu 10
ans est très très fortement pour ce
grand prix
voilà donc il aura la possiblité nous
montrer toute l'étendue de son talent et
on attend beaucoup d'argent donc un
grand prix du sénat ça me dit
donc 6 mai et dimanche 7 mai dimanche ça
démarre donc samedi vers 15 heures je
crois à 15h30 c'est la dimanche à 11h
12h30 je crois 10h30 aux aînés
n'oublions pas la simultanées qui suit
et l'asim d'années qui suit vers 17h ou
18h enfin je sais plus qui sera délivré
par qui sera délivré partie des scellés
champions c'est les champions bijoux
pièces c'est lé champion qui joue donc
boris spassky va jouer joël lautier
aussi je crois qu aussi alexei shirov
devrait jouer une ode au parti peut-être
ou peut-être plus et arnaud hauchard
donc les champions qui auront fini leur
grand prix vont se libérer un petit peu
de la pression en jouant contre des
amateurs et du pipole puisqu'il y aura
des invités des vedettes qui vont venir
je crois que josé giovanni le
réalisateur sera là donc il y aura des
gens un peu du site du show business qui
seront là pour jouer un peu contre les
champions bien moi je dirais qu'une
chose ne manquez pas cet événement parce
que c'est vrai que des gens comme
spassky comme shirov sont des gens qu'on
voit tout le temps dans les magazines on
a l'occasion de les voir là en direct
faut pas louper ça voilà donc je vous
donne rendez-vous à la semaine prochaine
pour la conférence de presse mon talent
du grand prix du sénat pour le prochaine
émission de diagonale l'actualité
internationale du jeu d'échecs